do you want to speak with confidence
like these amazing personalities every
single one of these amazing speakers
have taken the same program with brother
Muhammad arshad Muhammad arshad has
helped develop all of us it's extremely
beneficial to do this course definitely
recommend this course
to access the free life-changing
training now
brothers and sisters and dear friends
their names right this was an
interviewer asking many people who've
been very very close and MMA sport have
fallen out does he ever think that him
this is his reply to this and I want to
tell you guys something so sweet in
Islam that many of us don't understand
which is a loving for the sake of Allah
watch this interview and let's come back
um
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
four things that are material or other
things
I never understood the concept of loving
for the sake of Allah I thought what
does that mean can I not love somebody
because I just love him why does it be
have to be for the sake of Allah then I
understood that I was a human being and
like it or not individually we sometimes
want like somebody as a friend or
business part or whatever it may be
because there is some sort of benefits
subconsciously you might think no no but
deep down sadly that's the truth
now when we come to understand loving
for the sake of Allah it goes beyond all
boundary boundaries it transcends all
boundaries why because when you love
someone for the sake of Allah this is
what you're saying imagine I give
somebody money to I lend the money I
help him multiple times with his family
matters Etc one day he comes to me and
hits me or slaps me or insults me or
insults whatever it may be yeah now
inside should I be feeling as I wish I
never did a b c and d and all the stuff
that I was there for you Etc first the
Allah says in the Quran do not nullify
your Deeds by mentioning the stuff that
you've done for others number two the
moment you stand up for the sake of
Allah do you know what that means that
means even if this person wrongs you or
does whatever it may be like when the
prophet's wife is
um slandered by someone Abu Bakr Adela
used to give money to he was planning on
cutting the money that he used to
support him with and Allah said this
Ayah that I mentioned to you before
saying what that basically do not
mention the favors and also so that you
should carry on given why because it was
done for the sake of Allah meaning your
reward is with Allah you don't expect
anything from him even if he turns
around and backstabs you or whatever he
does you're like you know what no
problem I did what I did for the sake of
Allah you might be upset okay you might
be upset about it and you might want to
warn other people in a way without
backbiting but it doesn't mean that you
start be mentioning the favors that you
did and all this kind of stuff this is
what loving for the sake of Allah means
brothers and sisters and the more we
don't implement this the more you see
people falling out
and I give you guys a very simple
reminder
and all the problems that work in the
tower our objective is one defending the
Kalam of Allah making his Kalam the
highest and spreading tawheed anybody
that misses objective we are happy now
if our love to one another was based on
followers and what we gain and this that
and oh but you didn't give me a shout
out there oh but why are you doing this
video I could have done it there will be
fitna and there's one thing that I've
noticed and say Masha Allah
protect us from evil eye is that our
bloodship with our brothers around us
it's not pertaining to material things
I've realized even if we get into
disputes it's pertaining to the Deen not
pertaining to worldly matters and
Affairs and that's why you see many
people who fall out based on these
things brothers and sisters four huge
rewards that you can get for loving
someone for the sake of Allah let's go
through this one one by one inshallah
and we'll end the video inshallah and
sisters the prophet sallam said there
are three qualities whomsoever has them
will taste the sweetness of Iman to love
Allah in his messenger more than anyone
one else to to love a slave of Allah for
only for his sake the prophet peace be
upon him said Allah will say where are
those who loved each other for my sake
and my glory today on a day when there
is no Shea but mine I shall shade them
with my shade the third major reward the
message before him said Allah exalted
has said for those who love one another
for the sake of my glory there will be
seeds of the of light on the day of
resurrection and they will be envied by
the prophets and martyrs subhanallah the
prophet sallam said amen a man set out
to visit a brother in faith in another
town and Allah sent an angel on his way
when the man when the man met the angel
the latter asked where do you intend to
go he said I intend to visit my brother
in this town the angel said have you
done any other favor have you done any
other favor to him he said no I have no
desire except to visit him because I
love him for the sake of Allah the
exalted and glorious thereupon the angel
said I am the Messenger to you from
Allah
from Allah to inform you that Allah
loves you and as you love him for the
for his sake brothers and sisters isn't
that amazing may Allah make us among
those who love each other for the sake
of Allah and nothing else and that is
the true form of love because you expect
your rewards from no one but Allah
till next time brothers and sisters may
Allah and brother Islam firm on Islam
and all of us